yeah there's words that you thought were
fine a few years ago and not just not
okay anymore jake paul thought were fine
a few years ago
who knows you know
but like but but
i think and charlemagne made this point
but like british people know there's
like certain words that have different
meanings here than back home cigarettes
like there's a cigarette word yeah back
home is something crazy yeah yeah it's
not like we look at drill rapper that
when they're saying that we're like ah
you gotta change that yeah
it is the most english thing to do
you're going to change your language
colonials
we're not going to let you colonize
beyonce
a black woman a black woman it's [ __ ]
up that is [ __ ] up yeah i it's
i don't know i feel like with music it's
freedom of speech isn't it it's yeah
you're open to just say and do
within reason anyway but like
to say and do what what you like but
yeah i don't know like i i guess with
beyonce she's got
you know a certain type of audience and
she has to try and please her audience
and yeah if that means changing a line
you've got i guess
there are people here suffering from
spas that are upset about it
what do you call them spazzers i
i have no idea that's a porn
i have no idea bro i have no idea oh
this is just mind-boggling
okay especially in the genre of music
where like wild [ __ ] is being said every
single day yeah like drill you're
getting people talking about oh yeah i
stabbed this guy and i stopped this guy
uh last week i also shot this guy but
anyway yeah
do you believe the shooting stuff yeah
in england yeah yeah yeah people have
guns in england but is it like a
communal gun like how do you get access
to it's like a library
yeah you have a card and you'd be like
i'll take it yeah yeah i mean i
allegedly yeah
i'm not getting trouble here but i know
like we're about to find out why wasabi
is
i guess if you want to get a gun you can
get a gun yeah yeah it's but it's like
it's hard yeah it's very it's it's way
harder than it is in america in america
bro you could just yeah walk in
when i was in l.a a few weeks ago
just walked into like
a sweet store yeah it was just
gunsmithing that was duty-free at the
airport yeah
yeah exactly
it was awesome yeah yeah it was great
bro i was like well it's so cheap yeah
it's so cheap yeah it's cheap yeah
and i also think it's less savage to be
honest with you i think shooting someone
is less savage than stabbing well it's
kind of more cowardly
yeah that's yeah that's right yeah i
mean like i would rather shoot you from
like afar yeah yeah yeah like be up all
up close
you calling us [ __ ] right now yeah
like was it more comfortable for you to
potentially shoot something i'm not
podcasting
career time
shot from afar i was pretty pushy with
it
and then you could like miss on purpose
and they don't know that you're [ __ ]
you know but like the stat thing like
you can't even miss it's not but i mean
like there's something really personal
and like
horrible
you're staring at someone in their eyes
while stabbing them yeah and you just
see the life
like seep out of them
[Music]
you just see like on on the news like oh
he's dead he's like oh [ __ ]
yeah yeah
yeah it's it's white is it is it a bad
with the the knife that sounds pretty
bad really yeah yeah yeah it's pretty
bad so they're just walking up to i'm
trying to understand this now do you
feel more comfortable doing it because
like you know why you say me
just hypothetically like when you start
i don't stand anyone bro when you risk
kissing brilliance yeah i'm a brilliant
i'm saying it now i ain't on the streets
like that bandana bro i don't know
[Music]
and you know
is there ever a feeling like after like
stabbing somebody where you're like the
healthcare was taken care of you know
like
you know what i mean we're like you're
like you know they'll be all right yeah
nhs yeah
[Laughter]
it is a weird so like uh our boy jamil
who's here he does all our partnership
stuff he has international health care
he doesn't even have health care at home
isn't that weird that's so what wait so
if
he got shot in america would he just you
have to wait for a british ambulance to
come over
it's like days it's [ __ ]
nightmare
dude
yeah no he travels a lot so i guess it's
it's beneficial but it's so much cheaper
than just getting the health insurance
at home
yeah but how often do you go to the
doctor right well i mean it depends if
you can put it in the head for money oh
yeah or if you're on the streets like
that bro
you probably
once in a while but you can't go to the
doctor and ask questions and [ __ ] you
know i do i do remember like i had a
headache or something like that no i'm
not a headache i um burst my eardrum and
i was i had like pain this was before i
was fine logan yeah i was sparring some
like
120 kilogram guy we don't know what that
is
oh
sounds really little 100 oh really right
260. no okay double oh there we go
something like that two two point two
yeah okay two seconds so he hit me with
a zombie hit me with a left hook but 120
is like you got your eardrum
okay go on well hit me with the left
turret burst my age on my side [ __ ] yeah
yeah so then i was traveling obviously
to go to vegas to get something and i
was like oh i've got like a ear pain so
i helped the doctor and i was like oh
yeah like a doctor in america can i get
sword so he came over sorted me out he
was like yeah that's uh 1 500. yeah
i was like you've given me tablets yeah
you've just given me tablet and that's 1
500 yeah [ __ ] yeah it's like 50 bucks
for a tylenol at a half yeah whoa yeah
no wonder people are there like all
right [ __ ] yeah yeah
let me get the knife yo start the show
not us we don't set the prices we just
treat you oh is that right yeah we'd
just be treating you if you had a
private practice you could decide how
much if you could said the prices would
be way more expensive
yeah that's true probably that's true
that's not wrong and the medicine would
be shittier